[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen Folge Tatort Deutschland ich bin
Natalie Strauß und ich bin Mirco Kasimir
hallo wir wollen euch heute eine ganz
besondere Familie vorstellen sie ist
jetzt nicht besonders exotisch oder
irgendwie schräg aber es gibt einfach
ein paar Dinge die man sich merken
sollte und ein paar Vorkommnisse die im
Rückblick vielleicht ein bisschen
verdächtig wirken ihr werdet in diesem
Fall keine Nachnamen hören wir könnten
sie abkürzen dann hieß er einer B Punkt
und der andere F Punkt aber vielleicht
ist es einfacher wenn wir uns das mit
den Nachnamen schenken also unser
Ausgangspunkt sind die Geschwister
Elisabeth die 1954 geboren wird und ihr
zwei Jahre jüngerer Bruder Ernst Rudolf
ihren Eltern gehört eine Apotheke in
Stuttgart Möhringen das ist ein
Stadtteil im Süden des Zentrums
Elisabeth studiert als junge Frau
Pharmazie bricht das aber wieder ab und
geht in die Werbebranche sie heiratet
einen gut verdienenden Mann und als
Folge einer bösartigen
lymphdrüsenerkrankung bleibt sie
kinderlos das Paar lebt in Taunus einem
Gebirge im Raum Frankfurt Elisabeths
Bruder Ernst Rudolf bleibt in der Region
Stuttgart er bringt es zum Job eines gut
bezahlten Managers und heiratet 1981
seine Freundin Benedikte am 3 februar
1985 wird die gemeinsame Tochter Anna
geboren das einzige Kind der Familie
während der Schwangerschaft war bei
Benedikte die türkische Erkrankung
Multiple Sklerose ausgebrochen
schon bald nach der Geburt musste sie
Krücken benutzen was man auch wissen
muss die Eltern von Elisabeth und Ernst
verkaufen ihre Apotheke in
Stuttgart-Möhringen sie haben das
Rentenalter erreicht und keines der
erwachsenen Kinder will das Geschäft
übernehmen dadurch Erben Bruder und
Schwester mehrere Millionen mag bald
darauf überschatten 2 Tragödien das
Leben der kleinen Familie am 17 märz
1987 bricht Elisabeth und Ernst Rudolfs
Vater in einer Tiefgarage zusammen und
stirbt kurz darauf Ärzte vermuten dass
er einen Schlaganfall erlitten hat und
nicht lange danach stirbt auch die
Mutter sie verliert im 18 November des
gleichen Jahres das Bewusstsein nachdem
offenbar schockartig der Blutdruck
gesungen war zufälligerweise ist bei
beiden Todesfällen Tochter Elisabeth zu
besuchen Stuttgart sie wohnt ja sonst im
Taunus wenn wir diese beiden tragischen
Todesfälle mal hinter uns lassen dann
gibt der Rest der Familie Anfang der
90er Jahre eigentlich ganz harmonisches
Bild ab die kleine Anna wohnt mit ihren
Eltern in Tamm hohen Stange bei
Ludwigsburg nördlich von Stuttgart das
spektakulärste an diesem 12.000
Einwohner Städtchen sind die beiden
Wassertürme die man schon von weitem
sehen kann regelmäßig kommt Patentante
Elisabeth zu Besuch sie lebt rund 200 km
entfernt in der Nähe von Frankfurt
Elisabeth sieht man anders sie genug
Geld hat sie fährt gerne luxuriöse
Sportwagen und hält drei Rassehunde
es ist der 20 Januar 1993 ein Mittwoch
einer freut sich dass ihre Tante zu
Besuch nach tam kommen soll
Elisabeth will am Tag darauf mit einem
ihrer drei Hunde zum Tierarzt im Zentrum
von Stuttgart man kann sich das so
vorstellen Annas Mutter die ja schwer an
MS erkrankt ist gilt er als streng und
achtet darauf dass die Tochter z.B im
Haushalt mithilft Tante Elisabeth die
bringt den ganzen Spaß und Glanz mit in
die Hütte die fährt ein schickes Auto
hat diese niedlichen Hunde und dieses
Mal hat die Tante auch noch versprochen
etwas leckeres süßes mitzubringen anders
Mittwoch läuft erstmal wie normaler
Alltag ist eben tut sie frühstückt mit
beiden Eltern der Vater geht danach zur
Arbeit die Mutter macht Wäsche und Anna
läuft zur Schule in der Ulmer Straße wo
sie die zweite Klasse besucht sie kommt
später nach Hause und ist ein
Wurstbrötchen und am frühen Nachmittag
kommt endlich Tante Elisabeth das ist
ein sehr fröhliches Hallo und die drei
Hunde bellen munter an der Haustür und
natürlich das versprochene Mitbringsel
ist eine Packung Pistazieneis für annas
Eltern ist der Besuch obendrein
praktisch sie wollen am Abend eine
religiöse Vortragsveranstaltung besuchen
da passt es ja dass die Tante als
Babysitterin da ist also machen sich die
Eltern nach dem Abendbrot auf den Weg
und Anna darf allein mit den drei Hunden
Gassi gehen als sie mit dem Bulldoggen
zurück ist gibt es endlich das leckere
Pistazieneis Elisabeth macht für Anna
eine Portion mit Schokoladensoße für
sich selbst ohne das Eis schmeckt der
siebenjährigen so gut dass sie insgesamt
drei Portionen verdrückt dann bringt sie
die Tante ins Bett
unter anderem Umständen wäre es
vielleicht ein bisschen albern so um
Detail über ein bisschen Speiseeis zu
sprechen aber das hier sind keine
normalen Umstände was jetzt passiert hat
die Reporterin Kerstin recht für die
Stuttgarter Zeitung so rekonstruiert als
anders Eltern nach Hause kommen
bestellen sich die drei erwachsenen
Pizza bei einem Lieferservice sie
trinken Wein und Essen Pizza als Anna
ungefähr um 22 Uhr nach ihrem Vater ruft
sie muss sich übergeben und ihr ist
furchtbar schlecht sie bitte ihre Eltern
nicht auf Tante Elisabeth böse zu sein
weil sie ihr so viel Eis und
Schokoladensoße gegeben hat
Anna darf ausnahmsweise noch bei den
Erwachsenen bleiben
sie sitzt auf dem Schoß ihrer Mutter zur
Linderung bekommt sie schwarzen Tee
sowie uzara an pflanzliches Heilmittel
das bei Durchfall eingenommen wird
hier geht es so schlecht dass die Eltern
sie mit ins Ehebett nehmen doch Anna
findet keine Ruhe mehr alle
Viertelstunde muss sie sich jetzt
übergeben hat Durchfall bekommt Krämpfe
der Vater verabreicht ihr Kohletabletten
Elisabeth geht trotzdem im Laufe des
Abends zu Bett für die drei anderen
vergeht die Nacht unruhig Anna er bricht
sich weiterhin und verliert am Morgen
gegen 7 Uhr zwischenzeitlich sogar das
Bewusstsein die Familie ist jetzt sehr
besorgt anna wird zum Auto getragen auf
der Rückbank sitzt mit ihr Tante
Elisabeth und versucht ihre Nichte wach
zu halten in der Hektik hat Elisabeth
sich nicht angezogen sie ist also im
Schlafanzug unterwegs erstmal geht es
zum Kinderarzt aber die Praxis ist noch
geschlossen also fährt Ernst Rudolf zum
Klinikum Ludwigsburg Anna landet in der
Notaufnahme endlich gibt es eine
professionelle medizinische Versorgung
schon bald darauf führt Anne auf der
Intensivstation betreut wegen der
Symptome halten die Ärzte frühzeitig
eine Vergiftung für wahrscheinlich die
Mediziner nehmen Kontakt zu den Experten
der Giftnotrufzentrale auf aber es gibt
nichts mehr was andere retten kann am
Donnerstag den 21 januar 1993 gegen 11
Uhr hört ihr kleines jetzt auf zu
schlagen
Wiederbelebungsversuche scheitern um
11:32 Uhr mit Anna für tot erklärt
wir müssen jetzt erstmal Luft holen und
dieses dramatische Ende verkraften vor
ein bisschen mehr als 12 Stunden hat
Anna mit ihrer geliebten Tante noch Eis
gegessen jetzt ist das siebenjährige
Mädchen tot und es gibt ein paar Dinge
die wir in diesem Zeitstrahl eintragen
müssen um den Fall für die spätere
Ermittlung zu verstehen noch während im
Klinikum Ludwigsburg alles für Annas
Rettung getan wird bricht Elisabeth auf
sie fährt mit dem Taxi zum Haus des
Bruders und ihren kranken Hund ab und
bringt ihn zum Termin in die
Tierarztpraxis
sie hat bei all dem immer noch den
Schlafanzug an nach dem Tierarzttermin
geht es zurück ins Haus des Bruders hier
duscht Elisabeth schminkt sich und zieht
sich endlich normale tagesklamotten an
sie fährt zur Klinik dort erfährt sie
von dem Tod ihrer Nichte und dort äußert
sie einen Satz der merkwürdig die
platziert wird sie sagt sie habe den
Geschirrspüler angemacht obwohl der nur
halb voll war darin waren das nur mal so
nebenbei erwähnt natürlich die
eisschälchen vom Vorabend na das ist
wirklich schon sehr schräg denn wenn
gerade deine Nichte gestorben ist also
wen interessiert er bitte der
Geschirrspüler ganz genau das ist ein
Gedankengang von Elisabeth der etwas
verrückt wird schräg sind nach Annas tot
übrigens auch die Fehler bei der Polizei
denn obwohl die Ärzte schon vormittags
auf der Spur einer Vergiftung waren
ordnet niemand an dass die Lebensmittel
im Haus der Familie gesichtet und
untersucht werden tatsächlich schmeißt
Mutter an den Tagen nach dem Drama
vieles weg und noch etwas das kann einem
zu denken geben als die Ärzte eine
Obduktion von Annas Leiche vorschlagen
ist ihre Mutter strikt dagegen sie sagt
am Tod des Kindes würde das doch sowieso
nichts ändern der Leichnam wird aber
trotzdem untersucht das Ergebnis anna
ist an Asien trioxid gestorben kurz
Asien das Gift riecht und schmeckt nach
nichts es löst spätestens nach zwei
Stunden ein Brechreiz aus das heißt Anna
muss am Abend vergiftet worden sein die
Dose ist in ihrem Körper entspricht dem
20 bis 50-fachen der tödlichen Menge es
gibt also nur ganz wenige Möglichkeiten
hinsichtlich der Vergiftung das ersehen
war in dem Eis das einer gegessen hat
oder in der Schokosoße im Tee oder in
etwas anderem im Haus der Familie oder
anna hat beim Gassi gehen mit den
Bulldoggen etwas tödliches zu sich
genommen das Eis hat Elisabeth aber auch
gegessen zumindest nach eigenen Aussagen
das spreche für die Schokosoße und zu
der anderen Möglichkeit wie soll Anna
denn bitte beim Gassi gehen mit den
Hunden mal so aus Versehen nebenbei eine
starke Dosis zu sich genommen haben
mögliche Beweise im Haus der Familie
wurden allesamt vernichtet
die eisscherchen wurden noch am nächsten
Morgen im Geschirrspüler gesäubert
sämtliche weitere Verpackungen oder
Speisen wurden weggeschmissen also Mirko
von Anfang an sieht das alles nach einem
ganz schwierigen Todesfall für die
Polizei aus es gibt im Prinzip keine
Beweismittel und wir haben uns noch gar
nicht auf die Suche nach dem möglichen
Motiv gemacht zwei Wochen nach anastod
geht bei dem Hersteller von dem das
Pistazien als stammte ein Erpresserbrief
ein darin fordert ein Unbekannter der
sich Mister calva nennt 80.000 D-Mark
und droht andernfalls Eis Produkte der
Firma zu vergiften jetzt könnte man
denken aha anastas tot geht auf das
Konto des Erpressers aber erstens seit
wann verschicken dann solche Erpresser
ihre Drohung 14 Tage nachdem sie schon
vergiftete Ware ausgelegt haben zweitens
selbst wenn wieso war dann kein Gift in
Elisabeth heißt und drittens verläuft
die Spur letztendlich im Sande der
vermeintliche Erpresser lässt nämlich
nie wieder was von sich hören die
Polizei hat auch ohne diese dubiose Spur
genug zu überprüfen Sie durchsucht das
Haus in Tamm Hohenstein nach giftspuren
sie sucht Zeugen die Anna beim Gassi
gehen mit den Doggen gesehen haben hat
ihr vielleicht jemand vergiftete
Süßigkeiten zugesteckt und sie
durchleuchten die Erwachsenen dabei
kommt immerhin etwas Interessantes raus
sowohl Elisabeth als auch ernst Rudolf
besitzen zur Tat seit Wochen Schlüssel
zu der seit Jahren verkauften Apotheke
ihrer Eltern in dieser war auch nach
Aussage des neuen Besitzers noch Arsen
vorhanden aber es bleibt unklar ob da
jemand das Gift wirklich entwendet hat
auch im Haus von Ernst und Benedikt der
gab es aus Altbeständen noch Asien
allerdings nur in geringen Mengen die
Kripo nimmt zunächst alle drei
Erwachsenen ins Visier denn alle wirken
merkwürdig gefühlskalt angesichts der
Tragödie und die Ermittler haben das
Gefühl dass die drei sich hinsichtlich
eines Tathergangs absprechen den
Eindruck würde ich aber auch bekommen
also ehrlich zum Beispiel der Umgang mit
dem beweisen
die eine stellt alles schnell in den
Geschirrspüler die andere wirft laut der
Essenssachen weg also das ist doch
höchst verdächtig im Zuge der
Ermittlungen wird auch der Tod der
Eltern plötzlich wieder interessant
schließlich war Elisabeth bei beiden
Dramen in der Nähe der Vater starb mit
nur 65 wie aus dem Nichts an einem
Schlaganfall die Mutter nur kurz darauf
an einer Art Kreislaufkollaps hatte
Elisabeth schon damals ihre Finger im
Spiel dazu würde ja vielleicht passen
dass die Pharmazie studiert hat und sich
mit Medikamenten und Giften auskannte
andererseits was hätte denn das Motiv
sein sollen die Apotheke war ja schon
verkauft die Million schon vererbt noch
schwieriger ist es ein Mordmotiv für
anastod zu finden was hätte ihre Mutter
zu so einer Grausamkeit bewegen sollen
hatte sie wie die Kripo mutmaßt durch
ihre MS Erkrankung und durch die
Medikamente Wahnvorstellungen die sie
zur Mörderin machten auch bei Elisabeth
ist die Motivsuche total schwierig die
Staatsanwaltschaft argumentiert
schließlich so da die Tante aus
medizinischen Gründen selber keine
Kinder bekommen konnte sei der Mord in
einer gewissermaßen eine
eifersuchtshandlung gewesen schon ein
Jahr zuvor so hatten die Ermittler
herausgefunden sei Anna bei einem Besuch
von Tante Elisabeth übel geworden es
gibt also weiter viele Theorien in
diesem Fall und wenig Konkretes
trotzdem kommt es zum Prozess oder
besser gesagt zu einer juristischen
Irrfahrt in einem ersten Verfahren wird
Elisabeth vor dem Landgericht Stuttgart
zu lebenslanger haftverurteilt das
Gericht stellt sogar eine besondere
Schwere der Schuld fest das ist
angesichts sehr schwachen Beweislage ein
echt krasses Urteil sie könnte dann auch
nach 15 Jahren Haft nicht raus
tatsächlich legen Elisabeths Anwälte
Revision ein der Bundesgerichtshof hebt
das Stuttgarter Urteil im August 1996
auf danach verhandelt das Landgericht
Heilbronn den Fall mittlerweile
schreiben wir das Jahr 1997 wieder wird
Elisabeth zu einer lebenslangen
Haftstrafe mit Feststellung der
besonderen Schwere der Schuld verurteilt
es folgt die zweite Revision und er muss
kurz zu machen der Bundesgerichtshof
beendet das ganze mit einem Freispruch
für Elisabeth Begründung der Richter
anders Eltern sein zu früher als
Schuldiger ausgeschlossen worden
und auch eine mögliche produktvergiftung
durch den dubiosen Erpresser wurde nicht
gründlich untersucht nachdem der
Todesfall an sich schon ungewöhnlich war
gilt auch das juristische Ende als etwas
Besonderes normalerweise fällt der
Bundesgerichtshof keine eigenen Urteile
oder Freisprüche sondern verweist die
Fälle zurück an die untergeordneten
Instanzen aber hier platzte den Richtern
sozusagen der Kragen sie erklärten
weitere Prozesse wegen der miesen
Beweisführung für überflüssig aber mal
ehrlich das kann ich auch verstehen man
kann Elisabeth bei der unübersichtlichen
Spurlage nicht einfach für immer
wegsperren aber es macht einen irgendwie
auch unzufrieden ich meine irgendjemand
muss ja schuld sein am Tod der kleinen
Anna ja Elisabeth die Eltern oder
irgendjemand unbekannt ist der er Gift
zu steckt natürlich ich finde egal wer
es wirklich war er oder sie kann keinen
nachvollziehbares Motiv gehabt haben
wir haben in unserem Podcast ja schon
viele üble aber naja nachvollziehbare
mordgründe kennengelernt Habgier Hass
Eifersucht macht Hunger Rache aber was
sollte beim Tod von Anna passen naja die
Spur mit dem Lebensmittel Erpresser
bleibt ja irgendwie aber das ist echt
ein Fall der einen nicht loslässt und
naja gut erzähl mir jetzt noch mal wie
es weitergehen und da gibt es nicht viel
annas Eltern zogen bald nach den
Prozessen Weg aus dem Raum Stuttgart und
fingen in Franken ein neues Leben an und
anastaste Elisabeth er lag wie zu
befürchten schließlich ihrem unheilbaren
Krebs leiden anna wurde neben ihren
beiden früh verstorbenen Großeltern
begraben
den pistazien-eisfall haben wir mit
Artikeln von Bild Bild am Sonntag und
Welt erzählt sehr hilfreich war auch der
bereits erwähnte Artikel von Kerstin
rech aus der Stuttgarter Zeitung die
rechtlichen Aspekte finden sich in einem
ausführlichen Eintrag des juristischen
Portals HRR strafrecht.de das Skript für
diesen Fall hat uns Stefan Netzeband
vorbereitet Aufnahme und Schnitt wie
immer durch die fabelhafte Antonia Heia
fußproduktion weight watch Studios
München wir danken euch fürs zuhören und
wenn ihr Anregungen oder Kritik habt
dann schreibt uns gern bei Instagram
oder schreibt uns eine E-Mail